Now when you make these changes and
look at the results in DevTools,
you should see that the box
sizes are different but
there's not actually any change
to the layout of the page.
First, let's take a look at our My App
page before we make the change.
Notice that the image is 595 pixels wide
while the description is
also 595 pixels wide.
It's basically the length
of our current screen.
Then, when we add our CSS style,
save, and refresh,
note that our image is now 460 pixels,
which is how we defined it.
Then, when we make our changes and
refresh the page, notice that the image
is now maxing out at 460 pixels,
and when we resize the screen
our description then
maxes out at 705 pixels.
The layout,
however, has remained unchanged and it's
still not looking like our design mock.